here's what would happen if your brain  stopped working for five seconds well  the short answer is you'd be brain dead  and brain death is irreversible though  at that moment it would just seem as if  you're in a deep deep sleep  unfortunately your brain wouldn't come  back to life five seconds later  without any medical intervention brain  death would lead to multiple organ  failure hypothermia and respiratory  failure your cardiac muscles would start  to die and within an hour or so your  heart would stop about one week after  your brain death your kidneys would  start to fail and so would your immune  functions that's because your brain  would no longer be creating the hormones  needed for all the biological processes  in your body if there's one bright side  to all of this at least you wouldn't  suffer yeah you wouldn't feel anything  as you'd be completely dead so